les émissions importantes de certains
gaz qui s'attaque à la couche d'ozone
ont été détectés en chine ces substances
interdites depuis 1987 ont été repérés
grâce à la vigilance de scientifiques
internationaux
on parle de ce problème à la connexion
avec renault mais n'oubliera gagner qui
est avec moi renault on croyait que les
menaces pour la couche d'ozone était
chose du passé par l'école au nom
malheureusement non je pense que d y ait
des choses qui reviennent nous hanter
comme ça dans la vie
donc ce qui était annoncé cette semaine
c'est que ya certaines régions
industrielles du nord-est de la chine
qui émettent jusqu'à 7000 tonnes par an
dans la grâce qu'on appelle le cfc 11
donc ceci j'ai produit qu'on utilise
pour par exemple la fabrication
d'isolants pour maison mais une fois
qu'ils aient dans l'atmosphère ce gaz de
vaud se met à attaquer la couche d'ozone
qui est là la couche de gaz protectrice
qu'on trouve partout autour de la terre
et qui nous protège des rayons
ultraviolets du soleil donc sans couche
d'ozone le serait s'exposer au soleil ce
serait extrêmement dangereux et dans les
années 80 monde a découvert que les
émissions de cfc faites par les
activités humaines savez année si une
énorme région de la couche d'ozone
directement au dessus des pôles et
jusqu'à les chercheurs ont calculé que
jusqu'à 5% de l'ozone total de
l'atmosphère qui avait été détruite par
les activités humaines
donc si on rien qui avait été fait si
2065 on aurait perdu jusqu'aux deux
tiers de la couche d'ozone ce qui aurait
été catastrophique
heureusement avons mis en place le
protocole de montréal qui est un traité
international qui maintenant été ratifié
par tous les pays des nations unies et
qui leur impose de réduire leurs
émissions de cfc et de les éliminer
complètement mais ce qu'on a vu cette
semaine c'est que certains pays qui est
content de ces restrictions il mais on a
appris ça grâce à des scientifiques qui
ont fait tout un travail c'est après ce
que c'est exactement ce depuis quelques
années les chercheurs avaient des doutes
que certains pays violait le protocole
de montréal parce que les cfc cd gaz qui
reste très longtemps dans l'atmosphère
et donc eux mesurent et leur
concentration pour s'assurer qu'ils
diminuent comme prévu et réseaux
remarqué une anomalie
c'est ce gaz le cfc 11 de baisse époque
comme il aurait dû le faire
donc ce que ça voulait dire que quelque
part dans le monde il y avait des pays
qui avait recommencé en maîtres donc
l'horizon règle les chercheurs ont
traversé des échantillons d'air qui
provenaient de stations partout à
travers le monde entre deux
lui et et 2017 ils ont fini par la
plupart des cas ces échantillons a
montré que le cfc diminué comme prévu
une station au japon qui suivaient pas
cette tendance là et il y en a une autre
en corée du sud qui elle mène à l'est en
direction inverse donc là en analysant
la composition atmosphérique la balade
les trajets en fait de ces gaz dans
l'atmosphère
les chercheurs ont fini par identifier
que ces gaz ne revenait du nord-est de
la chine
est ce que quelque chose qui est fait en
ce moment au qui va être fait pour
arrêter ça des enquêtes sur le terrain
ont montré en italie d'identifier
certaines des usines fautif
donc les propriétaires de ces usines
reçoit qui était pas au courant de la
réglementation soit ils utilisaient le
cfc pas sur l'or ça leur permettait de
faire des produits qui coûtait moins
cher donc les autorités chinoises disent
qu'ils ont fermé ses usines là et
arrêter les personnes fautives là il
reste à savoir où était produit le cfc
parce que pour éviter que ça se retrouve
dans d'autres produits industriels et
l'autre problème c'est que les usines
qu'on identifie en chine ça représente
seulement la moitié des émissions de cfc
qui ont été détectés par les chercheurs
donc il leur reste à trouver cet autre
moitié est là pour l'instant on essaie
on sait pas encore quel pays il faut de
ce fait si bon qu'on imagine que tout ça
c'est grâce leur ralentissent la
guérison de la couche d'ozone mais
malheureusement si on agit rapidement
mais c'est sûr que si les émissions
continuent ça pourrait le ralentir tout
ça donc le site si on arrête tout et si
la tendance se maintient on a estimé que
le trou dans la couche d'ozone
l'hémisphère nord devraient se fermer
d'ici 2030 celui au dessus de
l'antarctique devrait suivre en 2060 et
les choses devraient même s'améliorer
parce que il ya un amendement qui a été
mis au protocole de montréal qui est
entré en vigueur cette année et qui vont
interdire la production l'utilisation de
hfc souci un autre gaz qui attaquent la
couche d'ozone et on s'attaque à ces gaz
aux mêmes règles de problèmes en même
temps parce que les cfc sont un très
important gaz qui cinq mille fois plus
puissant que le co2 mais heureusement il
ya une très bonne volonté politique pour
s'attaquer à ce problème là le protocole
de montréal restons des protocoles d
être et et environnementaux les plus
efficaces qu'on a fait jusqu'à
maintenant et c'est un excellent modèle
pour la crise des changements
climatiques actuelles chose certaine
dans ce dossier là on imagine que ces
scientifiques l'avons continue sur les
stations daltrey prévention à tous les
jours ça c'est ce merci beaucoup et nous
ferait plaisir